Julien Courbet l'émission Ça peut vous
arriver je suis Julien Courbet
l'émission Ça peut vous arriver je suis
navré de vous déranger monsieur je suis
avec oui c'est courbé je suis avec
Sabrina chez Traoui
nous sommes sur les antennes de
l'émission Ça peut vous arriver à très
bientôt le verdict est tombé c'est la
mort dans l'âme que je vous annonce que
les trottinettes dans Paris sont
officiellement interdites
et même les gens qui ne sont pas à Paris
mais dans le Loir et Cher nous regarde
les parisiens étaient appelés à se
prononcer pour ou contre ces engins en
libre-service ils ont dit à 89% qu'ils y
étaient hostiles un résultat annuant
c'est tout de même l'abstention a été
très forte seule 7,5% des Parisiens ont
participé à cette votation à compter du
premier septembre prochain les 400000
utilisateurs revendiqués par les trois
opérateurs qui exercent dans la capitale
devront Kevin Gasser trouver un nouveau
moyen de locomotion
parce que j'y vais je vais à l'école en
trottinette et je me suis déjà cassé la
gueule dans la rue mais comme c'était ma
fille qui était devant celle qui s'est
fait mal moi j'ai rien eu assez de
d'adulte sur des jouets ridicules ça
suffit
elle a raison
le général de Gaulle sur sur une
trottinette avec son sac comme ça non
mais franchement pour respirer comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la vie
David je suis retraité je ne retraité
à 53 ans oui oui j'ai pris Marseille
est avec moi depuis le début de
l'émission puisque vous le savez tant
qu'un candidat ou une candidate n'a pas
fait tomber la cagnotte il ou elle a la
possibilité de revenir et je peux vous
dire que pour Magali c'est un exercice
compliqué puisque elle est obligée de
jongler avec sa professionnelle oui mais
j'essaye de rattraper tout ça à
l'antenne l'encourage David allez David
allez David la retraite à 53 ans allez
David
[Applaudissements]
améliore la période de votre vie
ça vous fait quoi comme effet et une
bonne blague sur Rire et Chansons ça
suffirait pas
ça
[Applaudissements]
dans mon papier alors je sais que c'est
vraiment mal poli
de enfin que ça se fait pas quoi qu'il
faut avaler quoi qu'il arrive et bien
maman ne sera pas fier de vous ce soir
je vous retrouve très pénétré et par
quoi
bonsoir Benoît
universités chinoises et bien dans une
semaine de vacances à leurs étudiants
pour leur permettre de trouver l'amour
les vacances de l'amour alors ces
vacances
à la télé la caméra vienne sur moi comme
ça parle d'amour pourtant j'ai fait
attention à ne pas te regarder tu
regardes là
on se complète pas mal je trouve
c'est déjà décrite à moi mais je m'en
fous complètement pour moi
personnellement le physique c'est
vraiment juste une enveloppe en papier
que tu vas à la poubelle derrière
le plus important c'est ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur c'est parce qu'il y a à
l'extérieur
Anissa mais bon franchement j'espère
vraiment qu'elle Lisa va ressembler à
ses photos
[Musique]
je vais montrer la vidéo qui a publié
l'une des universités pour justement
inciter ces étudiants à trouver l'amour
pendant ses vacances donc là c'est le
site de l'université avec plein de
confettis c'est assez festif et puis
vous allez voir on voit de jeunes
Chinois qui passent du bon temps des
moments romantiques au milieu des fleurs
et le message qui accompagne cette vidéo
c'est sentez le souffle du printemps et
découvrez la beauté de l'amour
ce que je peux pas écrire
c'est toi que je t'aime
beaucoup c'est Tania la productrice
ça va oui ça va et toi
j'ai un petit souci quoi 1000 questions
circulent dans ma tête à ce moment-là
pourquoi c'est pas ni ça qu'est-ce qui
se passe à ce moment là je me dis que
c'est la produite ça vient me voir c'est
qu'il y a forcément quelque chose qui va
pas écoute je suis désolé mais je crois
qu'à ça a changé d'avis
elle n'est pas là la vraie question
c'est combien de julia Vignali elle est
unique mais évidemment que les uniques
c'est la seule j'espère qu'elle nous
entend mais évidemment qu'elle vous
entend elle est en train de finir de se
préparer là elle finit retire son pyjama
mais elle est en pleine forme à la
population de la Chine est en chute
libre en 2022 la population chinoise a
baissé c'est la première fois depuis le
début des années 60 du coup la Chine
multiplie les initiatives pour pousser
les Chinois se mettre en couple et à
faire des bébés par exemple certaines
provinces et bah proposent 30 jours de
congés payés à leurs employés pour les
inciter à profiter au maximum de leur
lune de miel vous l'êtes unique Thomas
aussi bon Télématin tunique
à très vite sur France 2 dans un instant
la matinale de France info sur le canal
27 juste après je pense que la langue de
Thomas a fourché en fait ce que j'ai
peur c'est que les gens ils prennent en
pitch en mode oh miskine elle est pas
venue homme miskine il est aveugle
je crois que les gens ils piquent moi je
veux pas que les gens pensent que je
suis quelqu'un de fragile je suis juste
un mec qui vient de se prendre à lapin
bah écoutez je vais manger une petite
carotte d'ailleurs on a dans mes cheveux
les petites carottes râpées sinon
Ricardo un tout petit peu bourré a fait
sa demande en mariage super romantique
sur la pelouse de baseball des Dodge of
de Los Angeles classiques us a un peu
lourdagues pas autant que l'agent de
sécurité
lancer plein de balles sur cette menace
limite terroriste un genou à terre le
marié plaqué fait rire sur les réseaux
même si ce placage des intégrant aurait
pu le blessé grièvement voir pire mais
ricardo est indemne stéphanie a dit oui
et la réplique disproportionnée a encore
de beaux jours devant elle